as an Australian Canadian the Fahrenheit
temperature scale has always seemed a
bit arbitrary to me I mean why does
water freeze at 32 degrees why that
integer and what exactly does zero
represent according to many sources the
Fahrenheit scale was defined by setting
0 degrees equal to the temperature of an
ice salt and water mixture and 100
degrees being roughly equal to human
body temperature but that isn't true the
real story is much more interesting and
scientific August 14th 1701 was almost
certainly the worst day in the life of
15 year-old Daniel Gabriel Fahrenheit on
that day both of his parents died
suddenly from mushroom poisoning and he
was sent from Poland where he lived to
Amsterdam to become an apprentice
bookkeeper
but Fahrenheit couldn't stand his
apprenticeship and ran away so many
times that his employer put out a
warrant for his arrest
travelling from city to city around
Europe he became fascinated with
scientific instruments and in particular
thermometers in 1708 possibly seeking
help with a warrant Fahrenheit met with
the mayor of Copenhagen who happened to
be the famous astronomer all Romer Romer
is known for observing the eclipses of
Jupiter's moons and realizing that
variations in the timing of those
eclipses was caused by the time it took
light to reach earth in other words he
found a way to accurately measure the
finite speed of light but more pertinent
to this story in 1702 Romer was
housebound after breaking his leg and to
pass the time he devised a brand new
temperature scale with the freezing
point of water at 7.5 degrees and body
temperature at 22.5 degrees now this
might seem odd until you consider that
Romer wanted the boiling point of water
to be 60 degrees as an astronomer he had
experience dividing things by 60 so if
you take this scale divide it in half in
half again and in half once more you
find the freezing point of water 1/8 up
the scale and human body temperature 3/8
up the scale so at their meeting in 1708
fahrenheit learned of roamers
temperature scale and adopted it as his
own adjusting it slightly because he
found it inconvenient and an elegant on
account of fractional numbers so he
scaled them up to 8 and 24
and this is the original Fahrenheit
scale he produced thermometers for some
time using this scale but then at some
later point Fahrenheit multiplied all
numbers on his scale by for setting
freezing point to the now-familiar 32
and body temperature 296 it's unclear
exactly why he did this he may just have
wanted finer precision in his
measurements but I think there was a
better reason you see Fahrenheit was an
excellent instrument maker his
thermometers agreed with each other
precisely at a time when that was
unheard of he pioneered the use of
mercury as a measuring liquid which is
the benefit of a much higher boiling
point than the alcohol used in most
other thermometers at the time and for
these accomplishments he was inducted
into the British Royal Society and we
know that he read the works of Newton
boil and Hooke in which he would have
come across the idea that a one degree
increase in temperature could correspond
to a specific fractional increase in the
volume of the measuring liquid and today
a 1 degree fahrenheit increase in
temperature increases the volume of
mercury by exactly one part in 10,000 is
this just a coincidence well we'll
probably never know for sure because as
an instrument maker Fahrenheit was very
secretive about his methods but I think
the data strongly suggests that this was
the case so what exactly did 0 represent
on the scales of Fahrenheit and Romer by
many accounts it's the temperature of a
salt ice and water mixture the only
problem is there are different
descriptions of these mixtures and none
of them actually produces the
temperature they're supposed to more
likely I think they picked the coldest
temperature in winter set that is zero
and later used ice and brine to
calibrate new thermometers in his day
the Fahrenheit thermometer was the best
you could get but now his scale is only
used regularly in the Cayman Islands
Bahamas Belize oh and the United States
of America so maybe it's time we all
adopted the global scale of temperature
Celsius which by the way wasn't invented
by Celsius at all so that was something
a little bit different this video was
animated by Marcelo s Connie I've got a
link to his channel in the description
you know I became really fascinated with
tempered
scales after I saw the original Celsius
thermometer you can see that video here
now this video was supported in part by
viewers like you on patreon and by
audible.com a leading provider of
audiobooks with hundreds of thousands of
titles in all areas of literature
including fiction nonfiction and
periodicals and for viewers of this
channel audible offers a free 30-day
trial where you can download any book of
your choosing just go to audible.com
slash veritasium and I have a book that
I would recommend to you it is called
the structure of scientific revolutions
by Thomas s Kuhn this is a classic in
the history and philosophy of science
and it'll make you see science in a
different way because it shows us that
science is not just one process but
there are actually revolutions that take
place when big discoveries are made and
that really changed my thinking about
science when I first read this book ten
years ago so you can check it out by
going to audible.com/veritasium download
it for free and try out the audible
surface so I want to thank audible for
supporting me and I want to thank you
for watching